heute geht es um artikel 0 des
grundgesetzes
freie fahrt für freie bürger in absatz 1
heißt es die würde des autofahrers ist
unantastbar
er hat das recht auf freie entfaltung
seiner fahrzeug führungspersönlichkeit
absatz 2 300 km h auf der autobahn sind
mein gutes recht ich habe noch einen
termin absatz 3 drumherum bum bum bum
bum bum bum bum
deutschland hat kein tempolimit auf
seinen autobahnen und es damit in bester
gesellschaft machen wir endlich welche
länder verzichten noch auf ein
tempolimit auf autobahnen richtig
afghanistan somalia nordkorea und
deutschland das quartett der verkehrs
terror staaten ist damit komplett
ist das nicht ein bisschen übertrieben
die deutsche verkehrspolitik als
terrorismus zu bezeichnen
seit 1950 sind in deutschland 780.000
menschen gewaltsam im straßenverkehr
umgekommen
das sind mehr menschen als frankfurt am
main einwohner hat freie fahrt für freie
bürger ist ein heiligtum
die angst der politik vor veränderung
ist riesig bei einem tempolimit werden
wir alle sterben dabei ist es eher
umgekehrt
je schneller ein auto auf der autobahn
unterwegs ist desto wahrscheinlicher ist
es dass ein unfall tödlich endet wir
gucken uns das mal kurz an
ein auto fährt auf der autobahn
plötzlich ist etwas im weg ein kaninchen
ein baby 96 baby kaninchen mit
warnwesten sonst kann man die aus der
entfernung nicht erkennen also
vollbremsung
wenn das auto nur 80 km h fährt steht es
bereits nach 88 metern
denn ist 130 km h fährt nach 208 metern
bei 180 km/h sind es 3 178 meter
bremsweg und bei 230 km h langsamer man
fährt desto schneller steht man das ist
logisch wenn man zb 0 km h fährt steht
man schon okay wenn wir aus der war
sogar mir zu schlecht ohne tempolimit
sterben mehr menschen
trotzdem gilt auf 60 prozent der
deutschen autobahn kein tempolimit
was den amerikanern ihre waffen ist den
deutschen die freie fahrt auf der
autobahn wenn ein auto auf einen
menschen trifft ist das auto eine waffe
in ländern wie frankreich oder
österreich gibt es ein tempolimit von
130 km/h
in belgien darf man auf der autobahn
höchstens 120 km h da ist durch die
frage warum hassen diese länder ihre
bürger so die autoindustrie ist sowas
wie die deutsche nr
obwohl die fakten offenkundig sind und
keine andere industrienationen der welt
so ein unsinn macht ist die politik
ohnmächtig da hat die autobranche
natürlich recht
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung gefährden
arbeitsplätze in automobilindustrie
je schneller man fahren darf desto mehr
autounfälle gibt es desto mehr autos
können verkauft werden
so gesehen gefährte das tempolimit auch
arbeitsplätze in der
versicherungsbranche gesundheitsbranche
bestattungsbranche seelsorge die 30
aktion ist ein volkswirtschaftliches
fiasko der damalige verkehrsminister
dobrindt meinte 2015
zur wahrheit gehört leider auch dazu
dass notorische raser sich nicht von
tempolimits abschrecken lassen wer kennt
sie nicht diese argumentation weil sich
menschen nicht an regeln halten stellen
wir sie gar nicht erst auf ich erinnere
mich an weitere zitate von dobrindt zur
wahrheit gehört leider auch dass sich
mörder nicht von gefängnisstrafen
abschrecken lassen deswegen ist mord in
deutschland erlaubt wer 250 km h fährt
bedroht andere menschen mit dem tod der
staat schaut zu vor zurück vor zurück
cool cool sind sie für ein tempolimit
oder wollen sie dass dieser 6 bb
kaninchen sterben